hey this is presh tolwalker about a week
ago Twitter said goodbye to its great
Bluebird logo and embraced the era of x
the move has puzzled nearly everyone but
it's particularly mysterious for
mathematicians who are wondering why
would Twitter's logo resemble a
character used in mathematical
typesetting
this symbol for example comes from a
paper from 2004 called linearization of
class C1 for contractions of binoc bases
if you zoom in you'll see this character
very closely resembles the Twitter logo
while we may not be able to explain
Twitter's move we might answer another
question why are mathematicians using
characters like this at all
so the history is that mathematicians
often use chalkboards to present their
formulas to students
but when you get into more deeper
mathematics you might want to emphasize
particular characters so they stand out
on the board
so how can you Bold characters on the
board one practice emerge in the 60s to
double strike some of these characters
and it became known as Blackboard bold
interestingly this was able to be
recreated on a typewriter
so if you typed out particular letters
and you wanted to bold one of them you
could use the backspace then you could
hold down the space bar and press that
same letter and this would create a
double struck effect which was beautiful
and over the years this has become to be
accepted as a standard way of writing
particular symbols so let me go over
some of the common examples the double
struck n refers to the natural numbers
which are non-negative whole numbers it
can include zero it may not include zero
then we expand this to be the integer Z
for the German word zollin and this will
be the natural numbers and the negative
whole numbers
expand this to the double struct q q
referring to quotient for the rational
numbers this will be quotients of
integers
this gets expanded to the real numbers
which includes all of these previous
numbers and it includes irrational
numbers like the square root of 2 and
transcendental numbers like piene
then we have a set which includes all of
these numbers this will be the complex
numbers denoted by The Double struct C
this will include I is equal to the
square root of negative one and numbers
like negative one plus I root 3. these
are the most common examples of
Blackboard bold or double struck
characters
but mathematicians have found uses all
the different letters of the alphabet
double struck X can refer to an
arbitrary metric space but this is not
as common a metric space is a set along
with a distance function
so while we may never understand why
Twitter made this move we can understand
this interesting history of mathematical
type setting
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign